Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Oval Table of,
it's kind of a mix of
outdoor and indoor lighting,
it's very nice,
we're going to be answering questions
that we've never answered before
that we asked you to ask us,
and I believe that we have the people
who ask those questions present.
Ah-huh.
Right there.
So we haven't talked a whole lot.
Yeah.
Because we're like,
we're moving around, we're
going from thing to thing,
getting ready for the next thing.
How's your Mythicon Rhett?
Well, I just took some Pepto.
I mean, I'm doing great.
I also just took some Pepto.
Yeah, I saw that.
I went up to Jenna
and she was in kind of a
group of people I leaned in,
and said, "Can you gimme some Pepto?"
What's happening for you down there?
Well, hopefully nothing,
and that's why I took Pepto.
But then, when you see somebody
taking pills, do you just...
That's not a good habit,
just when you see somebody taking pills,
then say, "Well, can I
have some of those pills?"
'Cause that's what happened.
Well, when I saw that you were chewing it,
I was like, "Oh, it's a chewable."
Yeah.
Well, that's really my jam.
You have a thing-
I love to chew.
Well, but also you have a thing
where you don't really know
when a pill is a chewable,
or a, what's the alternative, swallowable?
Swallowable.
Swallowable?
Yeah.
And I've tried to explain this,
that typically the flat discs are chewable
and the capsules are swallowable.
Right, but I'm pretty sure
you can chew everything.
If you try hard enough, yeah.
I mean, when it goes to your stomach,
it's like your stomach chews it.
I don't know, I feel like I'm
really getting the most out of
whatever I'm consuming
if I actually chew it.
That's why I chew pudding.
But no, I mean, I can see
that you're concerned about my stomach,
but it's totally fine, and
Link's is very much fine.
'Cause he's just taking
preventative Pepto-Bismol
at this point.
It's great, a little bit doesn't hurt.
And I think it makes your poops-
Real dark-
Purple.
Yeah, real dark.
Makes your tongue dark.
It's like the color of your jacket.
Hey, later on tonight
on our main stage show,
we can both stick out our black tongues,
because that's what happens
when you put that bismuth,
whatever the active ingredient is.
Now?
No, not yet, you gotta wait.
Okay.
Congrats on the show last night,
James and his Shame was awesome.
That was a lot of fun.
Almost too much fun
all at once, too early.
You seemed like
you were having the time of your life.
I was having the time of my life.
Jesse was having the time of her life too.
Yes she was.
I was watching from that
vantage point over there
for a little bit and I was like,
"Wow, I don't wanna be a distraction."
I went away and then I came back later
to give approving nods
of your performance.
I felt those.
But somehow, just based
on what Charles said
at the beginning of your podcast,
it feels like me and Charles
are in little bit of a competition.
I mean, I don't feel like I started it,
but he was talking about he
didn't want to show me up
and he didn't want me to show him up.
Right, right, yeah.
He kind of stole your thunder
when he made an appearance
and everyone was cheering
for him, not you.
Well, but I do want you to know,
just to be prepared today
for the next hour or so,
I don't have any barbecue sauce.
I'm not gonna do any
dancing demonstrations.
Man, you got Nancy up there, I love that.
Pretty great.
Pretty great, yeah.
Is that just-
That was like a thrill?
A typical Friday night for them?
I think so, yeah.
I love it.
It seemed like
it seemed very automatic
for them, didn't it?
You want to answer some of these questions
that we've never answered before?
Let's get to some questions.
You want me to read it?
So what we'll do is we got
a microphone down here,
we think that everyone who
has a question is present.
We'll just ask it and then we may ask you
why'd you ask that question?
Bonnie Stewart?
Right here.
Bonnie's right here.
We're gonna bring a mic to you, Bonnie,
but I'm gonna read your
question while the mic
is coming to you.
So Bonnie asks, "If you were a ghost,
what location, item or
person would you haunt?
Do you have life insurance
taken out on each other?"
Wow.
That's kinda like a hard left turn
in the middle of this inquiry.
Well, I can see how that
those might be related.
I like ghosts.
"If you're gonna die,
who do you wanna haunt
and does the other person
benefit from your death?"
Is basically the two-part question.
Am I reading this right, Bonnie?
Yes, I mean, basically I like
ghosts, so I have to ask.
And then, also I work in
entertainment production
and it's something my husband
and I have always discussed
is like, "I wonder if they do that."
I figure you have to,
but I'm just curious.
Okay, well let's start
with the ghost part.
You seem like a demented person.
You're in the right place.
If you were a ghost,
what location item of
person would you haunt?
Well, I mean, first of all,
I think the most strategic
thing would be haunting you,
because I feel like it
would be a way for you
to continue to have a vibrant career.
You could lean into my ear and say,
"That one's not chewable."
No, I'm just saying that-
"Ooh, that one is chewable."
Yeah, I mean I would definitely do that.
I would give you advice,
but I'm just saying that
if you didn't want to have
to rethink everything,
it would be simpler for you
if we just continued to be
a duo, but I was a ghost,
kind of like that Smosh movie
"Ghost Mates", remember that?
Basically we would just
be following the plot
of "Ghost Mates".
Right, so T-Pain is now involved in this?
Ah, hopefully, yeah.
Would people see you?
You're not visible.
So I would just seem very, very fixated
on your memory.
I think I would function
like a typical ghost,
which is, I don't know
if it's real or not.
And that's what a lot of
people would think about you.
I think I would just call
you my imaginary friend.
Okay.
Which is not far from reality.
I imagine that you're my friend right now.
I don't know how to feel about that.
I mean, do you imagine
that I'm your friend?
I mean, I think, I believe
that you're my friend, Link.
Right, so, but if you
were to think about it
in an abstract way,
you'd be imagining our friendship.
And doesn't that make me
your imaginary friend?
Okay, technically yes.
Yeah, we can be each other's
imaginary friend, dude.
But who would you haunt?
It could be a new aspect
of our relationship.
Okay, we can talk about that later.
Whether or not we will become
each other's imaginary friends.
I know that you really
like scaring people.
Oh, I love it, yeah.
So you really, I hate your question,
because I don't like being scared
and I get afraid if I
need to scare somebody.
So it's like, I would
just be the worst ghost.
I think I would definitely
have to possess somebody.
Is that an option?
Demons can do that.
Oh, demons.
I don't think ghosts...
You wanna be a demon?
It's a different question.
Yeah, I'd rather be a demon.
I do think it would be fun though.
Again, I don't really know
what I believe about this,
but if I died and was suddenly a ghost
and it was like, "Oh,
that is a real thing."
I think I would haunt
a very popular atheist,
like Richard Dawkins.
So I would just give Richard Dawkins hell
until he breaks down he's
like, "Ah, they're real!
Ah, my life's work is ruined."
And then you're like, "It's just me Rhett,
that guy from the internet."
Yeah.
"It's started out as a
hypothetical question
in a live "Ear Biscuit"."
I don't know why I'm using that voice.
Is that the voice you would use?
No, I'd probably keep my own voice.
I mean, but it would be more ghostly.
Tell me to choose something.
No, I'm not gonna-
I know you're not my puppet.
No, I'm not gonna, you can
imagine that I did that.
You're not as cooperative as my dad.
Okay, second part of your question.
Yes, we did have an awkward
conversation with the people
who help us make these decisions
about insurance and such.
And we do have an insurance
policy on one another,
which is pretty-
It's wild.
Think about it.
I mean, 'cause you get to a
certain point and you're like,
"Well, what do we do
if one of us kicks the bucket?
Or when one of us kicks the bucket?"
And if it's sooner,
I think the other person gets
more money, I don't know.
Is that how it works?
I can't remember.
Do we have it on us?
Let's read the life insurance policy.
Yeah, I don't have it.
There's, yeah, so if
it's, is it one of us?
Is there anything wrong with talking about
the specifics of this?
Well, only-
Of course not.
Nothing other than the fact that
you will almost definitely
be wrong about it.
Other than that, yeah, it's totally fine.
I mean there was, it was
probably like 40 pages
and then you just get to a point
where you're just signing it and saying,
"Okay, this is something about if I die,
Christie takes over from me."
Christie.
Or she just gets the
money that I would get.
Based on the contract that I read-
And you gotta keep doing stuff.
Based on the contract that I read,
Christie might want you to die.
It's not, I have a lot to offer.
She gonna be sitting very pretty.
Yeah, that's how we designed it.
It's gotta be some silver lining.
It's gotta be really
sad if one of us dies,
but at least it's like, "Good gosh,
now look at all this money."
Here's the thing,
we talked about this on the way over here
and we made sure not to
tell Christie about this,
because we flew separately.
So Link and I and Jesse were on
and Stevie as well,
were all on the same flight over here.
And then Christie came with Shepherd
and Lando and Lincoln
later, and we were like-
'Cause we didn't want him to miss school.
And I was like, "What if
this plane goes down?"
Welcome to my world.
She said, "Welcome to my world."
The reason we didn't bring it up is just-
You're always thinking that.
I was just thinking
we didn't want you to think about this,
but basically what would happen,
and this is what we talked about,
was Christie would just be in charge.
That's right baby.
She said, "That's right baby."
And then very quickly it
turned into that Christie
was gonna do something with
Cassie, Stevie's girlfriend.
It was gonna be the
Christie and Cassie Show.
And we thought that that would be-
That would be great.
Pretty awesome.
Yeah, so what I mean,
but, so there you go.
The answer to your question,
we literally had to think
through all the scenarios,
was like, "Well if one of us
dies, what if both of us die?
What if I...?"
We figured it all out.
We're totally ready.
Ready to die.
Ready for it.
And haunt Richard Dawkins.
Just like the Biggie Smalls album.
Okay, next question is from Jasmine Lopez.
Where's Jasmine?
Oh.
Right here.
Okay, I love this question Jasmine.
Nice hat, Jazz.
Can I call you Jazz?
Jazzy, Jazz, Jazz.
Smooth like Jazz.
I could call you Jazzy, but
that's what I call my dog.
Keep it as Jazz.
This is, there's a lot here-
Peanut butter J,
long-legged peanut butter J.
Can I get to the point?
I'm allergic.
I also call him that.
I also call him Jazzy Jeff.
DJ Jazzy Jeff Props.
I call him that.
Jasmine says, "My man and I broke up,
who gets to keep you?"
Oh.
"Him that introduced me to you all,
or me that fell in love from
the second episode I watched."
Oh.
Oh wow, okay?
So first of all, you're here, he's not.
Exactly.
And the tickets were his birthday gift,
but since we stopped talking, I'm here.
So I thought that you would take
a special interest in this, because-
I'm very interested in this.
You have a tendency,
I've observed to believe that
if someone is into something,
someone else close to them
cannot also be into that.
One of the best examples of this,
and the earliest example of this was
when your stepsister
Emmy just liked music.
So you decided, you're
like, "I can't like music,
she's taken music from me."
The whole vertical of music,
not a genre, all music.
I remember like it was yesterday
when my mom told me that,
she said, "Now Link, Jimmy and I
we're getting a divorce and
you're still gonna be my son..."
She didn't say that.
And the first thing I remember saying was,
"Oh, thank God I can like music again.
I won't be related to
that stepsister of mine."
And now I love music.
So it's like a lot of good can come from
a really proper divorce.
You know what, you just,
sometimes life gives you lemons and-
I just threw them at him.
Make orange juice and let the
world wonder how you did it.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay, what's your
perspective on that Jazz?
On the lemons?
Just on, I mean it seems like
embedded in this question
is the same principle that you feel like
you both can't go on
liking us in the same way.
No, because he looks exactly like you.
So I'm stuck, yeah.
Oh, he looks
exactly like me.
Well, then why'd you break up?
She saw the life insurance policy.
Something like that.
Okay, well this has
gotten very complicated
all of a sudden.
So it seems like can you
each choose one of us?
Yeah.
And only watch, you only watch-
Half of the screen.
Do you wanna watch Rhett or
do you wanna just watch me?
Because you wanna watch
me 'cause you're over him.
Yeah, I understand that.
I mean, we did think for a
while about selling some sort of
device that you could place
over one half of the screen,
but then we realized that's just paper.
Yeah, and physical.com buy paper
so you can cover up the
one you don't like as much.
But interestingly what we could do
to make that even easier,
and I don't wanna sign our team up
for any unnecessary work.
But there could be-
Like we never do that always.
Yeah, that's one of the things
that happens when we talk
is that we end up giving
work to people by accident.
Right.
Stevie had to come up with
crabs inside of crabs last night.
She's gotta figure out what that means.
But I think maybe some sort of filter
that just edits one of us
out completely of an episode.
I think you should do the same thing
that we tell everybody to
do when they complain about
not being able to play
along with the games,
just put your hand over the answer.
Put your hand over the answer.
Reddit, is Reddit here today?
Is Reddit represented?
Okay, all right.
When's the second episode?
This guy's got an idea.
The second episode.
He introduced her and then she started
from the second episode.
Oh yeah.
On my own.
Why not the first episode?
The second episode was on my own.
The first one was together with him
and I was like, "Okay, that's potential."
And then it came out in my
YouTube list and here I am now.
Okay, so you just feel like
you got what you needed
out of that relationship.
Right, and now we're
getting twice the views.
Exactly.
All the welcome here.
Just agree to not talk to each other.
And see over the internet thing, yeah.
Matt Walker right here.
Okay, we've moved these
people to the front.
Hey Matt.
Hey, how's it going?
Great, now on a scale of 1 to 5,
how intelligent do you
think your question is?
Zero.
Off the chart.
Just so long as we're clear.
Right, yeah.
Matt, asked us,
"Do you think you could
survive for an entire year
only eating 5-pound
Velveeta cheese blocks?"
Followup question, "Just how thick
do you think your blood would get?"
Okay Matt, I have a question for you.
Sure.
Are you preparing for
some sort of challenge?
No, I can give some backstory if you want.
So at work, we work in
a room with no phones.
We get very bored and come up
with the strangest questions
that we can think of.
So this is just to pass the
time and we figure that out.
You said that you work
in a room with no phone?
We do, it sucks.
You get bored.
Yeah.
This the White House?
What are talking about?
Oh, you're not gonna tell us?
I can't, I'd have to kill ya.
Okay.
And take out
that life insurance policy.
There's a life insurance
joke in there somewhere.
Okay, why do you think
we can answer this intelligently?
5-pound Velveeta cheese blocks.
It turns out that's the
biggest block you can buy.
And we calculated that
if you buy one a day
and eat that whole thing,
it's about $45,000 a year
of just Velveeta.
Okay, so you've got the budget covered.
Right.
Let's talk about the health impacts.
That's the followup question.
$45,000.
Do you have to eat all
five pounds every day?
That's a challenge, I guess.
Well, that's not gonna work.
I mean, all you can
have is Velveeta cheese,
which is not even really a cheese,
it's probably a cheese product.
Right, mostly plastic.
Oh man, that would be a
rough year, first of all.
I can guarantee you that.
Yeah, I think it would
come to halt pretty quick.
The inner workings.
Can you drink water or
do you get the moisture
just from the cheese?
There's water in.
There's water in it, you're kidding?
Just all your moisture from the cheese.
If you squeeze a block of Velveeta
you get cheese water out of it.
A 5-pound block.
Yeah, that's important.
Yes, you're drinking cheese
water, eating cheese.
Hey, and there's a thing.
Christie is a cheese lover.
You're a cheese lover.
Christie got me cheese for my birthday.
I like cheese, but I
just don't understand.
I think it's something to
hear Christie talks about.
It is like there's something
that happens in her loins.
Well I don't wanna get,
I don't wanna say anything
inappropriate about your wife
while she's just behind
you in my line of sight.
She's not in my line of sight.
This is all on purpose.
But I do believe that the
same thing that happens
in your brain during
sexual stimulation happens
in your brain while consuming
cheese and chocolate.
So this might be something
you need to look into.
I like to stay hydrated
and so that's my thing,
through all intimate exercises.
I've heard that.
So now if she wants, if I want,
I'm gonna serve her I
guess Pizza and Velveeta.
Yeah, I've heard that you're
known to take a water break
in the middle of an encounter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe you could start
taking a Velveeta break.
You just keep a block of
cheese next to the bed.
I mean, that's a big block of cheese.
I think that might count
as like a threesome that.
Oh, okay.
A cheesesome.
"Just how thick do you
think your blood would get?"
You would die.
This is not a good idea.
But I do think you should try it
and I think you should
start a YouTube channel.
I'll send you the link.
Okay.
Do not do that Matt Walker.
Where you wanna go now?
You wanna go here?
Yeah, is this Evie or Eve Fields?
Yeah, right here.
Eve Fields, hello, Eve.
Okay, this is, this is a
multi-part question here.
"Now y'all know that there
we'll come a day when you retire
and stop creating content,
but if everything were to
disappear besides the merch
and the memories you've left on people,
what kind of impact or legacy do you think
you would have left in that
hypothetical situation?"
That's interesting, but hypothetical,
'cause how would that ever happen?
Yeah, 'cause we think about,
and we've talked about
on this show before,
just this reams and
reams of content over 16,
we're looking 20 years eventually
it'll be more than that.
So much of our lives are on the internet.
I mean, just look at "Ear Biscuits" alone.
And we've talked about how much is there.
I take strange comfort in that.
And now that you've taken that
away from me, hypothetically,
yeah, the merch on its own.
We got some good merch and
we got a lot of merch too.
We've said a lot of things on T-shirts.
But I don't know what
people would conclude
if they only had the merch.
They'd be like, "Were
they NASCAR drivers?"
One of 'em was a snake,
there's just so many
yeah, we're still good.
There's just a lot of
different conclusions.
Rub some bacon on it, that's a old shirt.
That was one of our first merch items.
It still works, the technique still works,
rubbing bacon on things.
Boil for safety.
There's just a lot of
things that out of context
wouldn't make a lot of sense at all.
Now if you got, if you got hold of
the "Book of Mythicality",
that would explain a lot.
That would help.
That feels like cheating at that point.
So let's just say that doesn't exist.
I just like he's got the feel good
Mythical Morning shirt on.
You know what?
I think that even through our merch,
there would be this message of feel good,
accept yourself, accept others,
and let's be nicer to people.
Yeah.
I do think that a lot of
the slogans that we put out
into the world are things
that come from our mouths
and our conversations,
but they also are just a great indication
of the relationship we
have with Mythical Beast
that we kind of feed each
other in that energy,
like you gather the people
that have similar energy
and I'm just glad that
when we meet you guys
at the meet and greet lines
or see your faces here
and we soak up your energy
that there's so much positivity,
there's so much acceptance
and a welcoming vibe
that everybody doesn't look the same,
everybody is not into all the same stuff.
It is an eclectic group,
but you have this...
Now, if you keep yelling, I
cannot keep a train of thought.
All right, kick that person out.
You are not accepted.
You were judged.
Well, you know what I was trying to say?
Well, I think that's my
favorite thing about being here
is that there's a group of people
who they get all of the inside jokes
and all of the references.
Because it's one thing
when you've got a friend
and you know somebody
in your town or whatever,
that's another Mythical Beast.
But I assume, and I can
kind of see it on your faces
that being in the presence
of other Mythical Beasts
in this way where it's
like this unspoken thing
is pretty cool.
That's what we were hoping for.
This is literally the coolest
thing ever for amazing.
And this isn't the first thing thing
I've ever seen with you guys.
So I just threw myself right into this.
Outstanding, 10 out of 10.
10 out of 10.
Well, I told Jesse,
'cause she hasn't performed
in quite some time.
You wouldn't know that based
on how she did last night.
But I kept telling her, I was like,
"You have nothing to worry about.
This is the warmest group of people
that you will ever imagine.
We could literally get up
there and just bomb so hard
and they would tell us
that we did a great job."
Well that's kind of the
reason I wanted to ask this,
because for me, what
you guys have given me
is so much more than just the content.
I'm not trying to get sappy
here, but I wouldn't have-
Do it.
Okay, let's do it.
I would not have come out as transgender
if it wasn't for you guys.
You have made such a
safe and welcoming place.
I have never felt more
accepted and loved here.
And you guys just exuded that.
And for me, the reason I ask this,
is because your impact
is so much more than
just the surface content.
I mean, yes, you're eating
crabs inside of crabs,
which some might say
is not the highest
quality content out there,
but just the way you embrace
the weirdness and all of us,
and also on "Ear Biscuits"
just being so open
about you guys' stories and
your own histories and journeys
just helps someone like me be like,
feel comfortable with
actually being curious about
themselves and exploring that.
So just, you guys are great for that.
And I really thank you for
just the positivity and love.
Thank you for sharing that.
Thanks Eve.
Now yeah, that means a lot to us.
And I wanna go back to the
beginning of that question
was about retirement, wasn't there?
Yep, retirement.
You're talking about retirement.
Let's talk about that for a minute.
We're at an interesting point
in our careers right now.
There's a lot of opportunity
and honestly there's a lot
of different directions
that we could take Mythical in.
And, but because and I think
a lot of it has to do with
being middle-aged.
Who are you talking about?
I mean, yeah, you've
broken the 45 barrier,
I think that's past middle-aged.
I think is, see for you,
you're past middle-age
and you just start to think about
all right, the future, you think about
by the time we're 50 in our early fifties,
then it's where the kids are gonna be out
of both of our homes.
You think about is there,
do we have the ability
to retire at some point
earlier than most people?
Conceivably.
We also have the ability
to like I was saying,
take the direction of Mythical
in a lot of different ways.
We're trying a lot of things
that aren't just about
the content we create,
but there's a whole business
side of running Mythical
and saying, all right,
what are the initiatives
that we want to invest in?
One example, the Mythical
creator accelerator,
you may be familiar with that we invest in
up-and-coming creators who
are building their own brand
and we want to be footsteps
that they can follow in
when our experience was
we really didn't have
anyone to emulate.
So we saw that as an opportunity.
It's a business opportunity,
it's a legacy play for us to say,
how do we invest in
up-and-coming creators,
help them benefit and build their brands.
It's totally separate from
Mythical, but by using
with our guidepost so they
can be healthy and thrive
and put their own version
of good out into the world,
that's very exciting.
But it's separate from
our own work as creators.
So at times we find ourselves
being pulled in many directions
or seen that our company
can be pulled, pushed, or sent
in all types of directions.
And I think, and these are
conversations that honestly
we've been having,
given where we're at in
our careers, I think.
Well, it's kind of the balance between
running a business and
starting new lines of business
as we continue to grow Mythical
and then remembering that we are creators
first and foremost
and sometimes it's just difficult to do
both of those things.
I think the thing that we're excited about
that we really haven't
talked about at all,
you'll be the first to hear about this,
is that we're really seeing
2023 as a reinvestment
in us as creators.
And you may be like, "Well, you
already make so much stuff,"
but I think that in
terms of some of those,
maybe if you've been
watching for a long time
and some of those early videos
that got you into the Mythical world
that maybe leaned a little bit more into
us expressing ourselves creatively.
That's something that we
really wanna press on in 2023.
But I think that as we think about
retirement in general,
the way I've thought about
this is even if we were to say,
okay, we're going to retire
and I'm gonna go live in
a little cabin with Jesse,
you're invited, Jesse.
Oh, how nice of you.
And I think you're the one
who might need an invitation.
And then, oh, I'm gonna
just do woodworking nonstop.
The problem, regardless of what decision
we made individually as what
we wanted to do in retirement,
there's no doubt in my mind
that we'd be trying to find
a way to turn that into content,
because we can't help ourselves.
And also turning it,
if I had a cabin somewhere
in an undisclosed location
and you had a cabin,
I don't know if you want a cabin
or what you want, whatever you want,
your version of a cabin.
Yeah, you really put me
on the spot, but sure,
I'd like for it to be really modern.
The van is what people are saying.
And I'll park my van at
my ultra-modern cabin.
But even in that scenario,
there would be some way that-
'Cause I like having a toilet
that's not in my shower.
Okay, good, I agree with that.
We would have, there
would still be content.
It would be like, "Hey,
we gotta do our podcast."
Go to the spot in your van
where you do the podcast.
I'll go to the spot in my cabin.
Because I think it will
be, I want to do that.
Not, well, we gotta do that.
Well, you think when you
think about retirement,
you think about being
able to begin to pursue
what you want to do and
what your passions are
if you're lucky enough to do that.
And I think that we're
just privileged to be doing
what we want to do already.
Already.
And there may be some
things that aren't as fun.
It's not as fun to run a company
as it is to make content.
So I think the thing that
is always going to be there
is going to be making content.
Yeah, I think that that's
a lot of the soul searching
that we've been doing recently has,
and conversations that we've been having,
but what are are the
next five years, 10 years
look like for us?
I mean, we are specifically
having those conversations
and the thing that really
invigorated the conversation
and it's like it kind of
felt like a light bulb moment
and it's what you just said
we find ourselves in this amazing position
to have the opportunity
to express ourselves,
because of all of you
even though it's like
without an audience, you
can't make things in a vacuum.
And the fact that there's
so much enthusiasm and trust
and excitement for what we want to do
and how we wanna connect with each other
and connect with you guys,
that that gives us a
good amount of freedom
and saying we can take even more advantage
of the creative freedom that we have now
by cooking up even more
things that we can share,
as opposed to working on things
in private and in secret,
and then hoping to develop them
by playing somebody else's game
and then no one ever seen it.
We've done a good amount of that.
We talked about that.
We did the whole "Ear
Biscuit", where we talked about
all the ideas that we had come up with
and all the movie ideas and TV show ideas.
And for years we've taken
a pretty big part of ourselves creatively
and tried to package it
in a way that we could
drive across town and have a meeting
with a group of important people
and trying to talk them into
letting us make something.
And after so many years of doing that
and just repeatedly being
told that this doesn't work,
or even when it does work
and they wanna do it,
they wanna put their spin on it in a way
that makes it not what we want it to make.
We're beginning to be like,
okay, stop trying to convince those people
to let us make something
and just start making stuff
for you guys directly.
We gotta figure out
how that looks and how
we do that as a company.
But that's where our
minds are at right now.
Yeah, and so you see what happens
when the word retirement enters our brain
and then it comes out as
how do we express ourselves?
I think that's exactly how
we think about retirement
is that we don't, I guess, in that sense.
But we do think about cabins, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe everyone says we do.
Very modern,
mine's gonna be rustic.
Okay.
Jasenya?
Right.
All right, your question.
It's pronounced Jasenya, sorry.
What is it?
Jasenya.
Jasenya?
Yeah.
"What emotion do you both feel the most?"
Oh, what emotion do we each feel the most,
or both feel the most?
My theory is that it's the same emotion,
but I'll let you go first.
Oh gosh, this is tough.
Christie and I just
went on a little getaway
into we went back to Big Sur,
and you lose reception,
so you gotta be strategic
about downloading what
you wanna listen to.
And we downloaded the audio
book, Brene Brown's book,
"Atlas of the Heart".
Highly recommend this book,
even though I only listen to
the first two chapters so far.
Usually, that's all you need.
Pretty awesome so far,
but she takes you through all
the emotions that can't exist.
I'm like, "Wow, there's so many emotions
that I didn't know I could have."
And she lays the groundwork
that it's really important.
It opens up your life to be
in touch with your emotions
and to be able to identify
more of them specifically
kind of, it gives you a vocabulary
with which to understand
your own experience
and thereby live a more robust experience.
If you just think,
well, I can just feel anxious
or I just feel sometimes I realize that
anxiety is actually anger,
or if I say I'm frustrated, it's like,
well, that actually may be anger.
But and then also saying,
hey, there's lots of different types of,
there's joy you can experience.
There's lots of positive emotions too.
That's what I'm trying to say.
I wanna experience all of the emotions,
so that's my recommendation.
I don't know if it's my rec today,
but "Atlas of the Heart".
Yeah, that should be the rec,
because I don't have one.
I don't know.
I don't wanna just go to anxiety.
That's definitely me.
Well, just be honest man.
But I think that that's probably my go-to.
Yeah, pretty good.
I got a pretty good
anxious sweet spot there.
It's just like, nestle
right down in there.
It's like, let that divot in
your bed where you're like,
oh, this is where I
lay every single night.
And I can tell if I shift over
two inches in the wrong way.
And it's like, oh, I'm back
in that anxious spot again.
Maybe I should roll over.
Roll over into joy.
"Roll Over to Joy" that's your book Link.
Okay, "Roll Over Into Joy"?
"Roll Over Into Joy", yeah.
Okay, I'd read that, I'd
read the first two chapters.
Is goosebumps an emotion?
Yeah, potentially.
But I totally appreciate
what you're saying
and that's something that
therapy has helped me with
is you feel something
and then you are if you lean into it
and you get to the bottom of it,
What is that?
Oh, there's something beneath it.
But generally speaking,
and this may be, this is I kind of figured
that's what your answer would be
and it may be surprising, it
may be even surprising to you,
but I think that as you
look at a list of emotions,
I think that anxiety is probably
the thing that is operating
the most often for me as well.
Now I may deal with it or it
may manifest itself differently
and people may not be like,
oh, I wouldn't have, you may not know that
even if you're interacting with me,
I don't tend to let you know
that that's what's happening.
But I was thinking about
the way that I interact with
this this weekend.
Yeah, one huge part of it is anticipation
and just knowing that we've thought about
creating this experience for you guys
that we've got a team
that knows you really well
and knows what you like and what you want
and picking a special spot like this.
But then right on the other side of
every one of those anticipations
is an anxiety about something
that could go wrong,
is the fear is we're gonna come down
and just roll through the whole town
just taking people one
by one and throwing them.
And then you're like,
"Oh, we made a decision
to do this outdoor event,
was that a mistake?
Is it gonna rain?
Yes, it's gonna rain on day 1."
And then things like, okay,
oh, the performance last...
I'm like choosing, where
am I gonna place my worry?
It's like, okay, I'm
gonna do this concert,
perform these songs that I've
never performed for a crowd.
You really wanna kind of
have warmed up a little bit
in front of some people,
but, oh, I don't have time to do that,
so let's, oh, it'll be
fine, let's just do it.
Jesse's got anxiety about it
and then there's there
just all the things.
And then we've got this ridiculous show
that we're gonna do tonight
where we're only doing the
things that we're gonna do,
because it's you guys and we know
that you'll have a fun time
watching us do something
that we probably wouldn't
take out on the road.
But yeah, so it's like a lot of,
and I don't necessarily
think I would call it
an anxiety disorder,
but it is definitely the general
thing that's always there,
just under the surface that
you can dip into at any point.
To be like, "Okay, yep,
that's something I can attach
some energy to right now
and worry and try to figure out."
Okay, I'm gonna change my answer to horny.
Okay, I don't believe that's an emotion.
You might wanna talk to
your therapist about that.
That's like saying that
your love language is sex,
which I tried to pull that one time.
Oh really, it's not.
Yeah, it can't be, it's not an emotion.
It could be physical touch,
but not always that
kind of physical touch.
Okay, but then I'll
just go with goosebumps.
Okay.
I feel like I've been pretty chill here.
No, and I think Jesse
and I were talking about
it last night.
How chill I am?
Yeah, how chill Link is,
because the thing that
you wanna be able to do is
and I feel like with each
year that I get older,
I get better at this, is
not just wanting something
to be over.
There's so much of my life
when I've had something like
that performance last night
or what we're doing tonight
where I'm just, I'm actually
sort of fantasizing about
getting to my hotel room and lying down.
And they probably don't want to hear that.
Yeah, right, 'cause they're
just, "Get through it,
don't screw it up and just
get to your hotel bed."
But that you're acknowledging
that something's wrong with that.
Yeah, and actually well, and
being able to talk to Jesse
throughout the past months
about her being a part of
this actually was helpful.
Being able to tell her
some of those things
that I would tell myself
was therapeutic for me,
'cause I was like, "Listen,
the experience is going to be
when it's happening,
don't let that slip by.
Anticipate it, look forward to it,
and then enjoy it when it's happening."
And I think that by
talking about that so much,
I actually, when it was over,
I didn't have a sense of relief,
I was like, "Oh man, I'd
like to do that again,"
or, "I wish that had gone on longer.
I wish that was still happening."
That's good.
Yeah, so I'm getting better at that.
So you didn't run to your bed afterward?
Well, we did run to the bed.
So, what are we learning here?
Yeah, it's like we've had the privilege
of experiencing so many things.
We lead a really wild life being able to
just live our dreams,
but yeah, there's something
to like we wrote about
in the book, like making a
decision to stop and celebrate,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, "This moment, I'm
here for it, I'm in it."
And I just wanna go back
to giving you guys credit
that you've created an environment
for us here that I'm not freaking out,
but instead I'm like, they
know what they're here for
and they know what they're gonna get.
So I just, let's just go with it.
You might as well not try too hard,
just let it happen, let it happen,
it's a safe space.
So I do feel like
I'm living it up.
I feel like I'm here-
I'm having a good time.
I'm having a good time
and it's so much different
when you go into a place
where you're having to explain yourself
or prove yourself.
So that's what I was talking to Jesse,
I was like, this weekend is built on
for some of you, it may be
days or weeks or months,
but many of you years of a relationship,
that we get to come in here
and have together for a weekend
and experience in person.
Jamie, how are we doing on time?
We got-
When are we supposed to be done?
I think we're just rolling
right along, we're good.
Oh, we're good.
So Mike Davis, right there
in the leopard print.
How you're doing?
Hey, Mike.
Hey.
What up Mike Davis?
What's going on?
I don't think we've
ever answered this one.
"What's your least favorite episode
of Good Mythical Morning?"
Least favorite episode?
Do you have an answer?
Somebody yelled out, "Ghost Pepper."
I mean, the Carolina Reaper.
Wasn't it worse?
It was worse.
Blind Taco, The Horseshoe.
Well, the ones that definitely-
People think The Horseshoe,
people think the Blind Taco, blind?
Blood Taco.
I was like, what's a Blind Taco?
I mean, if I think about
the physical effects
of an episode, I don't
even remember what it was.
It wasn't at The Ghost
Pepper, it was that other one,
The Scorpion Pepper where I
was in good Mythical more,
I was lying on the couch.
Oh yeah.
And I was just, I had lost the
capacity for entertainment.
I was beyond being energized
by the what was happening.
And I was just angry
and scared and anxious
and that was bad.
And then of course, the longest-lasting
negative physical effects
was that glass of vinegar
where it just led to like a-
A duo or don't-o.
With some mash.
And it was-
That was horrible.
That's the reason we ended up buying them,
because I was so angry about that.
It's like, yeah, "Don't
cross me, I'll buy ya."
To me, you think it's the Grape Nuts vlog.
Yeah, that was torturous.
See, I don't have an answer.
My least favorite GMM episodes
are the ones where it's like,
I think it would be if I
could come up with one,
one that I was really excited
about that then sucked,
'cause it's like, yeah, the food stuff
were miserable afterward,
but it's really hard
to point to an episode
that was a complete flop.
I mean, you might not
like some of the guests
and I'm not gonna throw
any guests under the bus,
so let's remove those.
We've had a few guests
that absolutely sucked.
Yeah.
Right, I think I might
thought start a Reddit thread
where everybody can just talk about
which guests sucked the most.
That'd be great.
We'll leave that for there.
But it's a real credit
to the Mythical crew
that makes the show.
I mean, you've seen the
evolution of the show.
It's changing over time
that they know the show and us so well
that they're setting up
parameters for the show
to happen to us.
It's a really interesting thing
that the thing our baby
is now something that
we've basically said,
"All right, we're entrusting
you to raise our baby team
and then bring our baby to us and then
see how we react to it.
Oh, it's my baby's back.
Oh, you've gotten taller."
It's like sending it
off the boarding school.
So it's this weird, it's this weird
like being just as committed
to Good Mythical Morning as ever,
just as excited about it as ever
and knowing that there's ways
that we can infuse ourselves into the show
even more by entrusting
our team and stepping back
from the matriculations of planning.
We've done that
increasingly year over year.
And I think it's really
having a positive impact
on the show,
because it gives us this an increasingly
more authentic performance
that's less and less
of a performance and more of
just an authentic experience
of us behind that desk.
So I can't find an
episode where it was like
I was so excited and then it just bombed
or didn't come together,
because they have all the right places
that matter most there
and so we can kinda mess around with it.
And I actually think that,
so the cliche answer I always give is who?
Mike.
But people ask the inverse like,
"What's your favorite episode?"
And I'm always like, "The
next one," because we do,
but what it's just like
we are excited about
where the show's going.
We're excited about the
things that we can do.
That desk, that set, that environment
is a playground for us.
And that's another part of
what we've been talking about
in realizing, hey, what
we've built together,
how can we take more
advantage of it creatively
to continue to push boundaries?
I mean, continue to eat stuff, yes.
We're gonna keep eating stuff
on Good Mythical Morning
and we're gonna keep
doing other things too,
'cause it needs to be fun for us,
it needs to be fun for the
team that's making it with us
and blind-siding us
with it a lot of times.
Yeah, and I think that some of our,
this wouldn't be a least favorite,
it's like when am I the most,
I'm actually changing the
way I think about this now.
We've talked about this
before on "Ear Biscuits",
when we try something that we
think is creatively ambitious
or we do something that isn't
us just eating something
and then it performs
at like half the views,
because that's the way the internet works.
But I know that's not how
you guys feel about it,
because you're very vocal
when you do like watching us
take a creative risk and
do something different.
And not only because you watch,
many of you watch every
episode or most episodes
and therefore you're not just like,
"I'm just coming in for this one
and I'm coming in for this one."
So we actually have you in mind more often
than it may seem like sometimes.
And again, that's that sort of
well this has gotta be a
business that supports the team,
but this is also a show
that is for us and for you
and for our collective experience.
So we're gonna keep trying those things
and we're not going to be
surprised or disappointed
if some of those things
that may require more effort
or more creativity or
more time from the team
don't get as much as many views
as just sitting down
and trying every flavor
of a Hot Pocket.
But we'll continue to try
to make trying every flavor
of a Hot Pocket as
entertaining and informative,
because these things matter.
Right.
Right?
Today we are eating another
block of Velveeta cheese.
Let's just do that for a month.
To turn that question back on you Mike,
do you have a least
favorite episode of GMM?
I do.
Okay.
Probably The Horseshoe.
The horse one?
Yeah, sorry.
It was a little boring.
Are you-
Ah, I was bored.
I almost died.
I didn't have anything to do.
I was like, "What am I doing here?
I don't think I should do anything."
Are you a horse guy?
I'm not.
Okay.
I don't know if that makes
me feel better or worse
that he's not a horse guy.
He just bored with it.
There was a whole level of
humor that you just didn't get.
Yeah, horse humor.
Horse humor.
Equine.
Yeah, yeah, some of them
aren't for everybody.
It didn't turn out how I
thought it would turn out.
Yeah, you saw my anxiety on full display
in that video, boy.
See it's important for other reasons.
It's important to be bored
sometimes by our show.
I had to take down all
my posters of horses
that I have up around my house.
Jesse was like,
"Why are all the horses
in our decor coming down?"
She loves horse decor.
It's kind of her specialty.
We're working on a Thanksgiving episode
that you were going to hate.
Awesome.
It doesn't involve horses
but you will be bored.
So don't miss it.
I won't.
Okay, the last question I'm not 100% sure
is Abigail Naylor here?
Oh, we're gonna have to
toss that microphone.
You're way back there.
Way back there.
We just got the yellow card.
Got the yellow card?
Yeah.
This better be a good one,
if this is the last one.
It is, so okay.
They're right there.
Sorry I'm late.
Hello Abigail.
Hi.
So you had a question about friendship.
"What advice would you
give to us for maintaining
such a meaningful
relationship with each other
for the many years to come?"
Yes, that is my question.
This is my lifelong best friend.
Well, like 11 years
since we've been friends.
No, that's nothing.
So, no, yeah.
We got a long way to go to compete,
but she's just like everything to me.
I moved to a new state
from North Carolina,
moved to Louisiana with her.
I knew no one as a
little 11-year-old girl.
And she was the first person I met
the very first week I moved to Louisiana.
And she is just like,
if you know me, you know her,
if you know her, you know me.
So I just wanted to get y'all's advice
'cause y'all have such a great
lifelong relationship, friendship.
So yeah, that's just my Clarice.
So, yeah.
And what's your friend's name?
My name is Clarice.
Miss Clarice?
Yeah, like "Silence of the Lambs".
Oh yeah, you haven't, he hasn't seen it.
We actually both have the first same name.
We're both Abigail, but she
goes by Clarice, so yeah.
It makes it simpler.
Okay, I'm glad you knew her name.
Yes, I learned that a couple days ago.
'Cause I was gonna say
that's the good first step to friendship.
It is.
Having the same name also helps.
That too, she didn't tell me that
until two weeks after we knew each other.
She's like, "Oh, my name's
Abigail by the way."
I was like, "That's good
information to have Clarice."
Two weeks to find out her name.
All right, we gotta give
some good advice here.
It's the last question.
Well, we've answered this,
we have answered this question,
but we wanted to talk about it again.
Friendship, is not easy.
No.
I'll sing a lot guys, 'cause I'm a guy
and I talk to guys about
friendships sometimes
and they're like,
"Well, it's tough for guys sometimes."
We're guys, we have an
extraordinary friendship.
There's a lot wrapped up into it,
so there's a lot at play here.
In some ways, friendship
or even best friendship
is an inadequate description of the nature
of our relationship.
I mean, so we are best friends,
but when you're that and
you're also business partners
and your performers
who a cornerstone of your
performance is friendship.
I mean there could be some,
there's some unique challenges for us,
because there's a lot wrapped up in it.
It's certainly very important to us
to actually be friends,
because we care about each other.
But also, and then secondarily,
because this doesn't work if
we're not actually friends,
that would really suck.
You're saying that
if you make your relationship the product
and then the relationship is over,
that is a big problem.
We've never seen that happen before.
It's interesting, somebody
sent me something recently
that talked about how
the number of friends
in people's lives decreased dramatically,
because of the pandemic and specifically
number of close friends.
I thought you were gonna
say because of children,
which is also children
will kill friendships.
No, but specifically-
Especially babies.
'Cause of the social dynamics-
Oh my gosh.
The social dynamics-
I'll remember that.
The way that things
changed with the pandemic.
There is I would say an
alarming percentage of people
who do not have one close
friend, that has increased.
But the number of, and
this is something that
has just been moving in
that direction culturally
for a really long time.
So I do think it's more
important than ever.
One of the ways that we
have answered this question
in the past, we always
talk about communication.
I wanna come back to communication,
because one of the things that I've said,
and then we've talked about
this recently on our own,
is the way we would answer this question
on one of the tours,
I think it was maybe
Bleak Creek or whatever,
'cause there was a
question about friendship
that would come up a lot
and we would talk about
how having something
that you're a common goal
was key to a long
friendship and the fact that
we were building something together
and so you've got this baby
that you shared together
in the same way that like
a marriage may have kids
you pointed out, which I agree with
and why I think that that is somewhat true
and I do think it's actually true,
because for a lot of the
reasons that we're saying,
there's a lot of things at stake
and there's also a lot of
things that bring us back
into each other's lives 'cause
both of us tend to kind of,
I mean, you're more extroverted than me,
but in a lot of ways we can go
a pretty long period of time
without having meaningful
interactions with somebody,
'cause we have so many things going on
and there's a lot of
people maybe back home
in North Carolina that
were good friends with us,
that we're just not the greatest at
staying in touch with people
are initiating and maintaining
those long distance friendships.
So one of the things we're
thrown into each other's worlds
over and over again all the time.
We're constantly in each other's worlds.
So that's one of the things.
So there's no outta sight outta mind,
that's never gonna happen with us.
But you kind of pointed out
the inadequacy in that analogy,
because the negative way of seeing that
is you would say that
if it were a marriage
and people were just in the
marriage, because of the kids,
then the day that the kids
leave, the marriage is over.
And that happens all too often.
And you made the point that,
well that's only part of the answer
and probably not even the most
important part of the answer.
The answer is the friendship is valuable,
because the friendship is valuable
and the friendship
remains and is important,
because of the value that
the friendship brings,
not because of the thing that
you guys are building together
and the way it benefits
from your friendship.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, I think definitely.
When we're both excited
and going after the same thing
and we're in this
especially if we're in
like a creative flow,
it's very exhilarating to be there
with your lifelong best friend and to say,
we're going after this thing,
we're making this thing
and it's kind of a magical synergy.
It does feel great and it does edify me
and I think our connection,
but there's also that personal side to it
that's like, yeah, but
we're also actually friends.
I'm restating what you're
saying in other words that,
and I think this is kind
of where our answer is,
is that it takes a lot of work
to maintain a relationship,
and for it, I think it's very important
that we have given ourselves
permission to say this is,
we're committed to this
and it requires work
and there's times when it's not
going as well as other times
and given ourselves and
each other permission
to express our needs in the friendship
is something that
I think we're still learning.
I mean, we're still growing as individuals
like we talked about earlier,
getting in touch with your emotions,
understanding that there's a
lot more of those out there
that can be a part of
your experience like that.
It's a similar experience
of knowing how to apply
the principles of
relationship to a friendship,
'cause you think, well
you can fall in this trap
that friends should just be
friends, because it's easy.
You don't make friends,
your closest friends are people
that you just find
yourselves hanging out with
and having a good time with,
"Oh, I find myself liking this person,"
but that's not, a friendship
is not gonna thrive longterm
if you don't give yourself
permission to say,
"No, this is a relationship that needs,
that requires work and energy."
And a big part of that is
being vulnerable to say,
"Hey, in this particular
time I have a need
that's not being met that in
our friendship," or vice versa.
And so, and we've had those conversations
and I think that's something
that we haven't shared publicly.
We just say we leave it at communication.
But I think that's a little
more specific version
of that same thing,
'cause it's easy to say,
well you just gotta communicate,
you gotta talk things out.
But even after all these years
when you find that if
you have a certain need
in the friendship that's not being met,
it's a hard thing to say,
it's a very vulnerable moment.
And then on the other
side of it though is this
a renewed connection and a renewed bond
that I think we've been
through that a number of times.
Yeah so, this may seem like a tautology
or circular reasoning or
whatever you wanna call it,
but the best way to maintain
a friendship longterm
is to continue to be friends.
And don't expect it to be easy.
And understanding that it's a commitment.
And I think the same thing
applies to relationships.
We could really quickly transfer
this into marriage advice.
When we got into our
marriages it was under
very specific understanding
and we were in a very specific place
in terms of our worldview.
And in that worldview divorce
was not really an option.
Now we are different people at this point
and I think that there
are legitimate reasons
for relationships to end
and marriages to end,
but I think that we still
have to approach our marriages
as if divorce is not an option.
Obviously, there are circumstances
that could lead to that,
but I think that you have to go in
with the level of commitment
that this isn't going to be based on
continual feelings of romance
and friendships are not gonna be based on
continual feelings of compatibility
or this, the vibes are always good.
If that's what it's based on,
the moment that that ends,
it's just like, all right,
I got more convenient people or whatever,
it's something that's easier for me.
So I think that that's where
the communication comes in.
The communication is because things are,
when you're work on so
many things together
and you're together all the time
in the same way that you
get annoyed at your brother
or your your sibling,
that's the kind of
relationship that we have.
And so, understanding when
that's beginning to happen
and knowing when
conversations are required
in order to kind of break
through that and move
to the to the next step
has been really pivotal.
Is that good?
That's perfect.
It's more than enough, thank you.
All right guys,
you can always let us know what you think
using #EarBiscuits or you
can leave us a voicemail
1-888-EARPOD1.
Thanks for joining us at Mythicon.
We'll talk at you next week.
Love ya.
Hey, Rhett and Link, my name is Carlin,
we're driving back from Mythicon
and we just wanted to
say that seeing you guys
go up on stage and do what you
guys have always wanted to do
with James the Shame and seeing Charles
so proud of you guys and with of course,
ElkHound SnuggleBaby, you
guys absolutely killed it.
So awesome to see you guys
doing what you wanna do.
Hi Rhett and Link.
My name's Brett, I've been a
Mythical Beast a long time.
Mythicon was a blast.
You guys hit it out the park
and it was everything I hoped it would be.
I got to meet Myth's crew
members face-to-face,
which was so surreal.
Your guys' live performance
and the Time Gate Bit
sent me over the fucking moon.
I was dead laughing.
It meant so much to me to
to be here this weekend
and to share in the first ever Mythicon.
So I just, I wanna thank
you guys wholeheartedly,
the Mythical crew,
everybody working behind the scenes
keep being your Mythical selves,
especially you, DJ ElkHound SnuggleBaby.
Love you too James.
Hi Rhett and Link,
also known as James in the Shame
and DJ ElkHound SnuggleBaby.
I had a great time at
Mythicon, it was amazing
and I just wanted to
let you guys know that
this year has been really
tough for me and my husband.
We had a miscarriage and then to followup
failed IVF cycles.
But right before Mythicon I
had another, my fourth cycle
and the day after Mythicon I found out
that I got a positive pregnancy test.
So we're expecting,
and it just seems so fitting
with SnuggleBaby DJ name
just all magically came together.
So I appreciate you guys and
what you're up to and thanks
for just being your Mythical best.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.